hi e.t this is your girl peppa and your
girl egypt chris
and we're taking over what lie have i
said say a lot are you ready to go there
go ahead you ready how would you
describe this season of growing up
hip-hop overall it's definitely rocky
explosive outburst
just outburst of everything exactly yeah
i say very
trying i've been in reality for a long
time but
this one was rough you know because it
was
you know some family drama and personal
personal really personal personal
personal
things so yeah it was trying rough
challenging and some good times it was
some good times
yeah yeah yeah definitely i would say
that for sure
other than you know this part right here
she's been super supportive and all that
but not in my kitchen i want to cook my
jamaican food i don't want to think
about young thong
what can you tease for fans on
what's come um what's to come on the
final
episode this season okay a tea a little
tea a little tease for the fans
my performance showing people the cast
members everybody what i'm really about
and they don't they don't get too often
to see that so i'm really excited
i think that's you know you know with
your vocal knowledge
on nigel talking about it you know
you know trying to deal with it for a
while and then finally you know you
you you're at a place that you've got i
have no obstacles i haven't
road blocked that's exciting
oh well i can't wait for everyone to see
it i'm really excited
hit me with another one come on come on
i like this it's not that i like this
so everyone's family goes through their
fair share of drama
but ours happens to be in front of the
camera
how are we each other's support system
through it all
we are each other support citizen
through it all exactly
it's rough though because um
we talk about it how should we deal with
this but
it's like okay this too shall pass
that's that's what i'm a big believer
it's just staying strong with
each other and i'm always like remember
i'll be like you could eat yeah good
she's always checking in and so which is
very important to do
yeah i want to ask were you nervous for
me when i
first started to be on the show um
a little bit um i know reality can be
tough i mean he was like only 16. i know
you have a baby got on the show
um i knew that you could hold your own
um because i've seen you hold your own
so that part was good for me and for me
plus i'm on the show so i knew that i
will be having your back
right and i'm going to be riding and
dying all the way through
that's right my baby you still the baby
i mean there's some tough
personalities that's on this show you
know i think it may
make you stronger yeah but it's at the
end of the day
i think those things make you stronger
but don't kill you make you stronger
what made you agree to do the show
initially well
honestly i've always wanted to be a role
model for people i'm very spiritual
and i pray twice a day every day i've
always followed god
and i know right from wrong and i wanted
to come on the show to show people what
i'm about and show them
that there's more to me than just being
the legendary daughters
is there something about the season you
regret
would do over anything that i would
regret i try not to regret
because i know everything but
i would say communicate yeah i would say
communication
for sure would be either not as not
communicating as much as i should
would definitely be definitely be my
regrets
for this evening once again i'm like
janice
she's like no i can't do it the world
wants to see you nah
you're good keep them you're so good the
first time you were on a reality
series was the surreal life in 2005.
so what were you most nervous about
going into that
oh i was most nervous about living
with complete strangers like i can't
imagine
i mean i knew that it was so many
different personality i get along with a
lot of people but i didn't know
if i would right get along with everyone
which i did because i ended up meeting
my good friend caprice on the show and
to this day we are good friends we still
talk outside of that and
amazing so it was good it
it opened the door for reality for me i
tell you when did you
first realize i was famous in the
spotlight
oh well how can i not tell
you know when i you would drop off my
lunch at elementary school
big fur coat and you know sunglasses and
the teachers would just
get the teachers and students i don't
even know how kids my age even knew but
they're their parents they're teaching
the teachers would really gasp and be
like oh my god
i remember that but then the kids would
guess too because they're like this is
special something's wrong
i don't know i think their parents would
always play and it would also be when
you would take me
to your concerts and i'd be in front of
thousands and thousands of people
screaming your name yeah that would do
it
don't know how you do
what is your advice to me to deal with
the naysayers
i just say ignore them
stand in your truth do not let naysayers
define
you at all because you know who you are
stay strong in this in this game because
it's rough
so you got to stay strong you got to
take the good with the bad so
understand that i agree he was in here
doing shoots mom you see we was doing
shoots
[Music]
what you mean up in you was up in here
doing [ __ ] yeah all right all right
the good with the bad so understand that
i agree
so we moved in together during the
pandemic
how much do you love having sam and i at
the house
sorry i'm sorry even though
that's kind of funny
[Laughter]
i just know it's great it's it's it's
great
having you guys around i mean we bug out
we watch movies together those are the
great family
moments and and the cooking you know sam
being throwing down
i know in the kitchen yeah yeah
um but like i said
she ready to get stella ready to get her
groove hey i was keeping a thousand
egypt is the only one that could walk
around
the house with nothing on because
because she got that luxury these like
beyonce her mother so she could
i just to go to my kitchen you know i
gotta
put on something for sam to come
downstairs well yeah yeah he just but
i'm the only one that suffers you don't
freeze you
free eat like free spirited free spirit
she get to come on down with nothing i
don't have that luck for me to walk
around with nothing on
i love his heart i just i'm with it
though i love the fact that you know she
just gave me a fighting chance and
that's all i needed
what is it about sam that you loved the
most
oh definitely there's so much um that i
love the most i would say
is it's easy to say his heart but about
his heart
it's the fact that he's honestly one of
the most genuine people that i know
he truly goes out of his way to make
sure
i'm happy but not just me my loved ones
his loved ones he doesn't want anyone
not being okay
so he just goes out of his way to make
things
great and i love him for that this
moment i cannot believe it this is like
your first time
trying on a dress yes
i know this is really an important
moment i want a very
special wedding with all my close people
that i grew up with that are important
to me that mean the most to me i want
them there
okay wedding questions because fans want
to know
and your mama want to know too have you
officially set a wedding date
okay so it was supposed to be may 7th
as you know that didn't happen
[Laughter]
but it was only because of covet and
everything that it got postponed to that
date with all
all the answers that i had at that
moment i didn't have all the answers
that i needed
so definitely going to have it
next year 2022 is it going to be like
winter
but here you know what i mean
that's that look where's here here like
in the house house here oh no no not in
the house house
it's going to be here in the states
where everybody can come to it don't
have to be
out of the you know jamaica or anything
right
right but it's definitely happening yes
next
i want in january or february so you
know that's sumbu i don't think that's
too soon baby stick to the may
6th oh my gosh cause that's right around
the corner
it's old i mean yeah it is um it is
how you doing i'm good all right i'm
good
i know what i'm saying you're looking
good
thank you thank you catch me out
let me ask this question this is a good
one for me you have seen me go through
some relationships
ups and down what type of man do you see
me with
oh okay oh what kind of people let me
stop myself
you see me with i love everyone
let's love everyone okay go ahead what
kind of man you
okay after that quick after that
done no i definitely see i see you with
somebody
and you know that in your age range that
can keep up with you
that's what i mean right because i have
my fair share of the youngins huh yes
but i understood why because you're
because you
you have a lot of energy she's a big
burst of energy so
you need somebody that will definitely
not get tired they gotta get on the
viagra
i agree i'm dealing with only older men
now i
i it's just yeah but someone that truly
makes you happy and has made
that makes you feel something you've
never felt before i'm not trying to be
locked down
right now honestly i'm gonna keep it a
thousand not locked
down i've been yeah three divorces good
friends
with benefits for life yes
yes we do fwb friends of benefits that's
what you want now
is that like the final that is that
where you see the end
the destination for you just i think i
think i'm getting married again yeah
it's understandable it's a lot gotta you
forgive me i'm not gonna
shack it up guys
he'll guide you you don't trust me you
will get to where
you want to be i love you love you
you